hello everyone and the welcome to the
final round of the day one of the 2018
world blitz championship I don't know if
it's a bit too much to call it the game
of the day as they were there were so
many games played but the two of them
are the leading players after 14 rounds
of day one and it's really quite an
intense and amazing game so I will call
it the game of the day until a better
game of the day shows up and here cross
and faces Vladislav artemyev Ladislav
Artemyev is a very strong Russian Grand
Master in classical he's rated something
over 2700 but in both the blitz and
rapid he is rated over 2800 so quite a
fierce opponent and if he keeps
improving in in classical as well I
think he will very soon be considered an
elite player and also in the three days
of rapid he finished ahead of course and
he finished
I believe in fourth place Carsten was in
fifth place the same amount of points
but with a better additional criteria
and Daniel Du Bois of course winning it
ahead of everyone with clear first
so definitely an excellent game I do
hope you enjoy it again it's a bliss
game so we're not gonna overanalyze it
although there are so many cool
positions to to check out but ok our
time if goes for b3 the names all arson
attack g6 Bishop to b2 attacking the
rook so Knight to f6
we have g3 Artemyev prepares to develop
the earth to think yet or the other
Bishop as well Bishop to g7 Bishop to g2
and here calls and castles we have 90 to
f3 and now we have at the standard
already opening of the names of Larson
on the board and c5 by Carlsen c4 we
have these six castles and the e5 now
and okay Carlson has a very strong
control of the d4 square but he does
have a hole on d5 so let's see let's see
how everyone goes about to this d3 nice
to see six maybe this night is coming to
d4 at some point we'll see the white
still reserves the the chance to play
III so it's not sorry it's not that big
of a deal we have at Knight to c3 bottom
EF night to yet now this night is coming
to c7 course and wants to be able to
push b5 at some point
we have night study too and not nice to
see seven a three and it's a disposition
has played many times for those photos
who enjoyed the red tape it's
interesting also in the world blitz
championship in 2016 in Qatar Doha
Sergei Cara can play this position with
white against Greece shook and won a
very nice game with the white pieces but
here a good issue continued with rook to
b8 cross and goes for a5 and okay III
now we have a completely new game on the
board rook to b8 by crossing now further
preparing b5 and also getting the rook
out of that nest EA 8 squared that's it
the bishop is complete well x-raying
knights the d5 and now b5 and ok Queen
to c2 developing the Queen connecting
rooks Bishop to e6 and now comes a rook
81 with f5 by Carlsen creating this very
very nice phone structure in the center
and f4 we have B captures on c4 and here
everyone thought that B captors on c4
was gonna be played but then it's a
blitz game really not even a 5 minute
but bliss game it's a three minute plus
two seconds increment you don't want to
be looking at moves like rook captures
Bishop there and such in a in a blitz
game so here after captures D captures
not c4 was played and this allows
Carlsen to push this pawn in the center
so II for now the tension between
bishops is exposed the bishop capture
screen captures and now Knight back to
c3 we had night Stewie ate by Carlson
and g4 here Artemyev wants to push g5
block completely block off the Kings
side and then depends on what black
plays of the ideas like nice - a 4 or a
nice the b5 going after the d6 poner
possible you can then
Riemann over rooks over to the D file
and so on but here at Carlson plays h6
now g5 isn't really all that impressive
and we have G captures on H F 5 g
captures on f5 and now with this pawn
being so advanced you can see that how
many really important central squares
calls and spawns control so it's not all
that easy to make them white you don't
really have a move with the rooks you
don't have a useful move with the
shop you could go king h1 maybe maybe
try to remain over the rooks over to the
open G file perhaps 95 is an idea but
here Artemyev plays a really really
amazing movie Knight captures on d4
sorry but not to that night
this knife capture son d4 I don't know
if it makes a difference but cousin did
accept the offering we have pawn
captures Knight captures and not what do
you play with the black pieces two
points for a knight isn't all that much
in in a blade game with a very low time
on the clock until Coulson wealth brings
this rook into the game he's not really
a AB material here across one goes
Knights to e7 and prefers to shift the
night over to f5 but also controls the
d5 square if you play something like d5
too soon then you get pawn captures
Bishop captures and down after Knight
chapters on c5 you're actually losing
the game you cannot trade because of 96
winning the Queen and even if you try
something like let's say rocky 6 the
control the 6 square you're gonna get
rogue d1 and the bishop is now lost you
can defend it once but still captures
captures e4 attacking the pinned piece
black is lost here so here at Causton
decides to slowly remain over the night
and 97 we have rook to d1 bringing the
roof to the nice D file Queen to c7
getting the Queen out of the D file and
now Knight back to g3
preparing ideas like efore f5 maybe
night to h5 will be an idea in the
future so Carlsen trades Knights 95 with
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
II for Bishop back to h7 Queen to c3
check King has to move we have King to
g8 and now comes C 5 and if you look at
this position yes cross and is of
material but until the Queen the rook
and this Knight find any any sort of
meaning white is definitely better this
ePHI move opens up the d5 square for the
bishop which will be an excellent
attacker cross and says okay no problem
bomb capture Sonny 5 who hit F capture
Sonny 5 and now Knights the g7 by
Carlsen
Bishop to d5 check King to h8 and now
comes east 6 and already artemiev has an
amazing passed pawn on e6
so how does cousin deal with this Queen
e7 he decides to block the
but now comes rope to have seven forces
calls in the capture on f7 rook captures
pawn captures now creating a passed pawn
on f7 and the rook to f8 cross and
decides to block it
we have rook to e1 attacking cross since
Queen Queen to g5 check King h1 now the
threat is rook to g1 and after that
everything connects Carson would be lost
and cousin finds the absolute best move
Bishop to d6
artemyev attacks the Queen rook to g1 we
have Queen to a5 the bishop is now still
protected and here we have Queen to e3
attacking the h6 pawn here Carlsen
played King to h7 relatively quickly as
both of them only have a very little
time on the clock
he played King h7 but also possible was
Bishop captures on f7 a giving up the h6
pawn and then simply blocking with the
Queen and then white of course cannot
afford to trade Queens Queen has to go
back now bushel captures pawn captures
now White has created a past the D pawn
but after look F 7 you will more will
you will be able to hold this will black
or white constantly has to keep an eye
on DF 2 square you don't want to allow
look to f2 with some nasty ideas against
the h2 pawn but okay Queen to III King
to h7 cousin doesn't want to give up
well eliminate this point but create the
past D pawn Queen to e7 and now comes
Luke captures on f7 alright okay Bishop
captures and now comes the Queen to f3
check Luke blocks and now Bishop
captures on g7 so Carson has a bishop
and the night for a look but how do you
activate the bishop and the knight h4
our 10 may have create some room for the
king he wants to play king h2 to unpin
here Bishop to g6 and now comes King to
h2 and okay cousin Queen to f4 check
when your opponent's is in a bliss game
you only have a couple of seconds on the
clock you always wanna if not you if you
don't have anything better you can
always give a check just again some more
time on the clock but also a nice Reema
nuvaring move for the Queen King to g1
now we have Queen to d4 check King to h2
Queen back to f4 check King to g1 and
Queen to d4 check cousin continues
they're checking he you know gains some
time on the clock while also conceiving
his plan
King to h2 and now Coulson does not want
to repeat the Queen to f4 check at the
reach threefold repetition in the draw
he goes Bishop to f5 he now wants to
play h5 and also Bishop to g4 the block
of the rook along the G file and tried
to create some more chances in this game
rook to g3 with Bishop to g4 now
preparing Age 5 and here are 10 we have
saw what Carson's plan was and he didn't
have a plan of his own here the best
idea is Queen to e3 now you have to go
for a queen trade but with little time
on the clock
Artemis played rook to g2 and here
Carlsen actually missed a beautiful win
cost and continue with his plan he
played h5 but there really is a
wonderful win here so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the the move
Colson missed in this position well I
have a nice tip of water so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations it's really well it's
once you know there's a move of course
it's a simple move to find but if you
don't it's especially with few seconds
on the clock it's really not not
possible but if you do it
congratulations and for those who just
want to enjoy the show Bishop to f3
seems reasonable you attack the rook
worse the rook gonna go the point is if
you go something like roof to g3 you're
getting checkmated Queen comes to f2
with check King has to move doesn't
really matter you can only go to h3 or
block with the rook and the receive
mating 1 we have King here Queen to have
to check now whatever you do either
block with the rook or King h2 and then
Queen to h1 is checkmate
on the other hand after Bishop to f3 of
course you can always allow black to
capture it then black would be just
winning but there's really no good
square to move the rook if you want to
control the second rank 2 to stop checks
you can't use f2 or d2 those are covered
by the Queen you can't use a 1 e to the
desk covered by the Bishop you can go
something like rook here but then Queen
to f4 check will be winning King Jiwon
now comes the Queen to g3 check King to
f1 and now you can go queen h3 check and
if you wanna either get checkmate it
here or
you can go clean 3-1 but now Queen h1
check King d2 and out comes Queen d1
check Kings III and Queen B 4 will be
checkmated so quite a quite a lovely
sequence if I do say so about okay after
Bishop to g4 rook to g2 was play the
Carson did not find Bishop to f3 with
seconds on the clock h5 simply continues
and now we have Queen to g5 by artemiev
and Carson goes for Queen to d6 check
but again Carson missed an excellent
move Knight to f5 which controls d7
square does not allow any checks for
black for white and it really prepares
this check or this check with with night
on f5 the position will be winning for
Carlsen any any move white makes let's
say a 4s there really is no we you SFIL
move Queen e5 check is coming King to h1
now comes Queen to e1 check I know
either you will go here and then face
Queen to c3 or you will block with the
rook lights the rubies you want but now
comes the bishop to f3 King H - Queen -
f - check King to h3 and now Bishop to
g4 check rook captures on g4 and now not
capturing but rather Queen to f3 check
and now you're either gonna block with
the rook and try to exchange everything
at face queen - h1 checkmate or you will
try to run with the king let's say King
to h2 and then you get phone captures
and now it's simply winning your upper
piece you want to play g3 the game's
over and any checks will be met with
Knights to h6 the night will be
controlling any checking squares and it
will be a quick kill for black so
another moment where Carson missed in
all of this craziness a win we have
Queen to d6 by cross and instead of the
Knight f5 King to g1 and now Knights to
e6 still with Knight to f5 would be a
winning position for Carlsen knight c6
with an attack on the Queen Queen to f6
and now cousin goes Queen to d4 he
forces a trade of Queens
Queen captures we have Knight captures
on d4 and now comes look to be - so
Carson still has a knight and a bishop
for a rook he's down upon but you know
Bishop to d1 at the strongest move we
have B for C captures pawn
captors and now a for Coulson hat now
has a past a pawn but artemyev has a
fast B and the past C pawn we have b5
Artemyev starts pushing the past pawn
and now Bishop to b3 blocking the rooks
control of the pawn so if the pawn ever
advances too far you can always prevent
it with nice the c6 b 6 but now comes a
three by Carlsen trying of course the
Queen D a pawn rook the b1 we have a two
and now rook to a 1
so cousin for starters rook all the way
to the a1 square and now captures the c4
pawn so now it's two phones each and
Carson still has a knight and the bishop
for a Rockwell this rook is extremely
inactive so it seems like a much better
position for black but still how do you
how do you make progress we have b7 by
white and now Knight to c6
of course gardening the BH square King
f2 now calls and brings the King over
into the game as well King III King to
f5 King to d2 Artemia wants to bring the
King over to defend the a1 square so the
rook can be activated not via that
square obviously King to e5 we have King
the c3 cousin tries to go for the b7
pawn with the King King Tubby - we have
King to c5 and now the rook finally
enters the game we have worked to g1 and
now kinkabe 6 Carlson wants to grab the
b7 pawn but rook to c1 and here's the
problem now the king is controlling this
pawn you will never be able to Queen it
on a dark square the rook is not
allowing the bishop to move and here
cross the plate looking to b5 Ruby Ruby
1 King goes to b6 rook c1 and after well
this was not played but it was in this
position after Luke c1 that the players
agreed to a draw as you cannot play
something like Bishop here to protect
the night and think ok I'll capture the
pawn next move because white will simply
eliminate the defender of the v8 square
and now it doesn't matter if you capture
with the bishop or with the King simply
white means the Queen enter the game and
of course is winning and there there's
nothing you can do here really so yeah
after this rook to c1 the players agree
to a draw and after this game they are
still sharing shared first I did prepare
the final standings not the final but as
you can see the standings after round 12
in first place we have Magnus Carlsen
and Vladislav Artemia with 9 and a half
points then we have a I believe five
players with five points Dmitry Andre
Qian
Janna pony 'she Peter Svidler young
sister of Duda in the onigiri
and then with eight and a half points
also we have one among how savvy a Iraqi
Shia Imam Yara and Anton horrible with 8
points 11 iron and yabadabadoo
severely goal above I think sadly
gullible in in the first 12 rounds of
the Blitz
has gotten the most rating points 70
point 6 also a lot of Kavala of 72.4 but
i think that's the most anyone gained
and it's interesting cross and is so
much higher rated than everyone you can
see there 20 939 rating in blitz and
even with a score of 9 and a half out of
12 he only one 0.6 rating points so very
interesting and also I've prepared it
this is these are the pairings for round
13 so this will be tomorrow and
tomorrow's games start one hour earlier
than today as it is the last day and we
will only have nine rounds not 12 runs
really a treat for round 1 Magnus
Carlsen versus onigiri so we will see
who is the master of Twitter as well
whoever wins this game will obviously
you know own Twitter afterwards but
definitely Svidler will have a have a
crack at the the young russian
grandmaster Vladislav Artemyev and then
we have pneumonia she do that
and Reagan correct in Madeira versus one
cow and 11 Arjun versus Anton horrible
only the first six boards swam that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it really
an insane game that could have gone
either way
first Artemyev sacrifices the the night
for two pawns then cross in defense
misses the win two or three times then
goes for the endgame then a really crazy
endgame and from that night sacrifice up
until the end game and everything both
players were under a minute so it was
really really really insane if you have
a chance you know do check out the live
it's not alive anymore but
there is a of course footage of day one
really just an insane game sir I would
like to thank Joel Quan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon with hopefully some other
interesting content and do join the
subscribers video 2019 I thank you all
and I will see you soon